vous avez des animaux de compagnie
probablement un certain nombre d'entre
vous puisque je vis grâce aux familles
qui ont des animaux de compagnie je suis
coach comportementaliste animalier et
j'interviens au sein des familles qui
ont des problèmes de relations et de
comportement avec leurs animaux et je
peux voir tous les jours à quel point on
peut aimer son animal et manger des
vaches en parallèle c'est la question
que je me suis beaucoup posé
pourquoi manger des vaches et pas du
chien vous allez me dire que c'est
culturel c'est vrai oui mais qu'est ce
qui nous pousse à suivre notre culture
à ce point je vais vous raconter une
histoire
quand j'avais 12 ans j'avais un lapin
nain elle s'appelait nahla elle était
grise je l'aimé beaucoup je faisais tout
pour qu'elle soit libre et comme
beaucoup d'enfants j'étais très
empathique avec les animaux c'est vrai
on ne verrait pas un enfant prendre un
couteau pour tuer un lapin ce serait un
petit peu bizarre
un jour je me prépare à manger
et qu'est ce que je vois dans mon
assiette de la viande de lapin l'horreur
sénat là que je voyais dans cette
assiette
alors évidemment je n'ai plus jamais
mangé de viande de lapin et ça m'a amené
un questionnement pourquoi mange-t-on de
la viande
grâce à mon métier et à ma passion pour
les animaux
je compare souvent les différentes
espèces
les espèces carnivores et les espèces
végétarienne et on peut voir qu'il ya
une grande différence anatomique entre
les deux les espèces carnivores
déplacent leurs mâchoires de haut en bas
exclusivement et les espèces
végétarienne déplacent leurs mâchoires
de haut en bas c'est vrai mais aussi de
droite à gauche
l'estomac des carnivores est aussi
beaucoup plus grand et plus acide
proportionnellement à leur corps que
chez les espèces végétarienne oui c'est
plus simple pour digérer de la viande
crue
on ne verrait pas un renard faire cuire
sa poule au barbecue l'intestin des
appâts des appareils digestifs des
espèces végétarienne sont beaucoup plus
grands en effet c'est l'organe principal
du système vg stif de végétariens alors
oui ce serait plus simple de mettre la
bonne naissance dans le bon moteur
évidemment mais on mange de la viande
quand même vous l'aurez me remarquer les
humains ont un système digestif le
végétarien l'autre question que je me
suis beaucoup posé aussi c'est pourquoi
manger des vaches et pas du chien qu'est
ce qui fait que dans notre culture on
distingue les animaux des deux
compagnies et les animaux dits de
consommation et bien c'est tout
simplement parce que dans notre culture
on aime les chiens et les chats et on ne
mange pas ce que l'on aime c'est aussi
pour ça que je ne voulais plus manger de
viande de lapin
ce qui est aussi intéressant de voir
c'est à quel point les vaches les
cochons les moutons les poules sont
représentés dans les dessins animés et
on peut les voir heureux
on peut les voir ressentir de la joie du
bonheur de la tristesse et de la
souffrance aussi bien sûr mais dans la
réalité celle inverse
dans la réalité on ne perçoit plus que
ces animaux comme des meubles des êtres
vivants dénuée d'émotion qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pour contre notre enfance et
l'âge adulte on les perçoit différemment
pourtant dans la réalité ces animaux
peuvent réellement ressentir des
émotions comme dans les dessins animés
les vaches les cochons les poules les
moutons sont des êtres sensibles et sam
inflige une énorme souffrance que de
devoir les voir souffrir
alors est ce qu'on a vraiment conscience
de nos actes moi aussi avant je manger
de la viande bien sûr j'étais pris au
piège dans cette culture dans cette
guerre psychologique permanente que nous
subissons entre notre nature empathique
et notre notre culture
pourtant il paraît que si on décide de
suivre notre vraie nature
on est plus heureux et en meilleure
santé
alors oui ça implique beaucoup de choses
y compris de se remettre en question y
compris de lutter contre cette culture
sociale cette pression culturelle mais
je pense que ça en vaut la peine
je vais vous raconter une autre histoire
j'étais chez une amie qui a un âne et un
cheval ces deux là s'aiment beaucoup et
ça fait des années qu'ils vivaient
ensemble
un jour je suis chez elle avec son
cheval pendant qu'elle emmène son âne
chez le vétérinaire
le cheval se mettent à hennir à souffrir
à transpirer jeu la contacter par
téléphone elle me dit que là ne vient de
mourir
les animaux aussi ressentent des
émotions et même à distance
c'est ce qui se passe quand des jumeaux
peuvent communiquer à distance
alors oui les animaux sont des êtres
sensibles et sont capables de stresser
lors de leur mort
et pourtant c'est ce que nous leur
infligeons que faire qu'est ce que vous
feriez si vous agissiez en pleine
conscience avec tout le processus qui
mène l'animal jusqu'à la mort est-ce que
vous deviendriez végétarien moi ce fut
mon cas en tout cas alors grâce à mon
métier de coach comportementaliste je
vois tous les jours à quel point on peut
aimer sans limite d'espèces à quel point
on peut considérer nos animaux de
compagnie comme des membres à part
entier de notre famille tout en en tuant
massivement d'autres alors j'ai espoir
que l'amour et le bon sens prendra le
dessus sur notre société notre
imagination pour comprendre toute forme
de souffrance animale de comprendre
qu'ils sont pour reconsidérer nos
rapports avec eux et j'espère que
l'amour que l'on porte à nos animaux de
compagnie nous entraînera tous faire le
respect de la vie sous toutes ses formes
et j'ai envie de finir avec une citation
d'albert einstein qui soit dit en
passant était végétarien l'amour est la
force la plus puissante qui existent
merci
[Musique]